We’ve just seen that acceleration somehow depends on force and mass.
We're going to design an experiment to figure out how.
First I want to find out how does acceleration relate to force.
Maybe a is proportional to the force.
Maybe it's proportional to 1/F.
Or maybe it's proportional to the force squared or something else. I just don't know yet.
But we can figure it out with an experiment.
In this experiment, we're going to take a 10 kg cart--that's its mass--
and we're going to apply differing forces on it.
We're then going to time how long it takes to go 10 m,
and using some of our motion equations that we learned in the last unit,
we're going to figure out the acceleration.
Once we get enough data, we can see how acceleration depends on force.
For the first one in the experiment, we'll push with a force of 10 Newtons,
and this is a new unit, but it's the unit we use to measure force,
and of course named after Isaac Newton.
We find that it takes a time of 4.47 sec.
Now, what must the acceleration have been?
You may want to use this equation,
and remember that the cart is starting from rest. Enter your answer here.